A Big Mac hat, and a cat-bunny salad, it's
episode 45 of IMG!
This tent was pitched high up above the clouds.
The snow and clouds make it look like a sky-tent.
But, can you find what's hiding in these leaves?
Make your Snuggy super by looking like Spiderman,
Batman, or Wonderwoman.
These double pupils are photoshopped, but
have you ever noticed that Sonic has it too?
His eyes are conjoined! They're like one big,
giant, white ball in his head, with two pupils.
Perfectlytimedphotos.com has some neat-o shots.
Lightning on water, head touching water, cat
not-yet-touching water, and a ping pong ball.
You're never too old to play.
And now, some unfortunately placed price tags.
Enjoy.
Tyree Callahan invented this color typewriter.
The keys use pastels to generate art, and
this poor seal was abandoned by all the other
seals because he was born a ginger.
Wet suits are funa and so are baby dolphins.
But let's get cuter. This dog is getting a
bear hug. Not enough? How about a Chimpanzee
feeding a tiger cub or tiger's licking.
Better yet? This guy who, no kidding, actually
stole a photographer's camera and snapped
these photos of himself.
Now, all of these animal images were on Buzzfeed's
list, a site where typing to Konami code rewards
you...kind of.
By the way, you can still play Pacman on Google
by going to Google.com/pacman.
And this product is not available yet, but
it's genius. Hamburger wrapping paper. Stack
gifts to make custom burgers.
If you have expensive tastes, try these name-brand
cereals concepts.
Artist Tim Schneider makes the world a better
place by putting big old eyeballs on things.
And this road in Norway looks like it goes
nowhere. But actually, it's just an oddly
curved bridge.
Now let's learn.
Dailyinfographic.com is sweet. Here's a history
of the word "Geek." From the word's origins
in the 1500's as "Gecken," meaning a "fool,"
to the middle period when it meant someone
obsessed with technology, or a certain subculture,
to the modern "Geek Chic" meaning where a
"geek" or "gleek" is a revered title.
And how about this one covering the chemicals
your skin takes in? Your skin absorbs 60%
of every topical product you put on it. Furthermore,
in her lifetime, the average girl will involuntarily
eat 4 pounds of lipstick.
On the subject of infographics, and charts,
and graphs, take a look at this: it's an illustration
of the Turkish empire's reach, made in 1801
by William Playfair, and it was the very first
piechart ever drawn by humans. Neat, huh?
On Monday I tweeted my excitement for owning
this book, because shadows are magic. Like
these two strangers who passed by each other,
though their shadows told a different story.
I also tweeted this illusion demonstrating
Troxler's Fading. Blurry, or faint colors
will disappear from your periphery if you
stare long enough.
Finally, I shot a gun for the first time in
my life. Destin was there with me and he
has this excellent scientific method for recording
muzzle flash and the shooter. You go from
this, to this.
He's gonna have a video soon where he explains
the entire process and how he made the photos
happen. But, in the meantime, check out this
video of the very moment I fired a gun for
the first time.
"You are the man. You're the man!"
Phew, that felt pretty good.
And as always,
thanks for watching.